CBS News travel editor Peter Greenberg
is with us now with more on what this
means for everyone and for Boeing and
let's start with the everyone at home
what does this mean for the traveler now
well it's been a problem for the last 7
months because this planes been grounded
since March it's gonna stay grounded
more than likely through April of next
year so there's been a lot of sort of
disruption in the schedule will this
plane fly again
you bet will it be recertified yes but
how quickly and then how quickly will
American confidence return to want to
even fly the plane because it's not just
the US regulators
it's the foreign regulators they've
already made public statements that
they're not going to rubber-stamp
whatever the FAA does so they're saying
we don't care if the FAA recertify the
plane quickly we're gonna recertify on
our schedule so imagine somebody wanted
to get on that plane knowing that it may
not be allowed to land in 40 other
countries so we're talking at least
April why do you think Boeing decided to
make this decision now why not three
four months ago easy to say that now the
point is they should have perhaps
because Muhlenberg was the public face
of the crisis and it was not handled
well remember he was the guy who was
lobbying the government and even
President Trump not to ground the plane
after all these other countries had
already done so he was also the one
arguing that they should recertify it
faster it got to the point where it was
questionable about their own
relationship between Boeing and the very
agency that was supposed to regulate it
and it got to the point last week where
the head of the FAA called Muhlenberg in
and said here's a little news bulletin
Boeing scheduled for recertification is
not our schedule so back off so with all
this going on it was time for a change
so let me ask you about David Calhoun
the new CEO he was chairman of the board
refreshing change or more the same for
the moment it was done to placate the
markets and to stabilize the company
remember he was actually on on on a
track to become the chairman and the CEO
about 15 years ago he didn't get the job
but he's a member of the board for the
last 10 years he comes from Finance he
was running global equity at Blackstone
and now he's got to just right the ship
because they've been losing so much
money at Boeing nine billion dollars at
Boeing just alone not to mention their
jobs and of course you're dealing with
all the suppliers and a 20% hit on the
company stock you talk about jobs what
about the rest of the airline industry
as well as Boeing as we move on
here well remember we have three
airlines in this country that are that
are operating the 737 max they have them
American United and Southwest
it's an optics problem right now so
United has already made a public
statement that when this thing gets back
in the air if you as a passenger don't
want to fly it they will react Amba date
you with no penalty now that doesn't
mean you're gonna fly on the plane that
you want on the time that you want or to
the route that you want but at least
they're already addressing a very big
public relations this is also a lesson
to other airlines who may know about
certain issues to really make sure that
they have certain things in check and in
place this gets into the culture of the
relationship between the FAA the
manufacturer and the airlines it's been
way too close for a way too long you
cannot dictate to the FAA who's supposed
to be regulating you they're not your
partner there are regulatory agencies
all right Peter Greenberg thank you so
much
you